Smart投資教室上課囉
嗨 大家好
我是仲葳
現在大盤
已經快要破5萬點了
可是為什麼
很多人的心聲
跟我一樣
覺得我的股票
沒有漲呢
台股在創新高
可是我的持股
卻在創傷
大盤紅通通
只有我的打開來
是綠油油這樣
到底現在
這波行情
有沒有可能
雨露均霑
大家都漲到呢
那到底我的持股
或是觀眾朋友的持股
是還沒有輪到
還是它可能
已經轉弱了
所以今天呢
我們邀請到
K線捕手
楊忠憲老師
現場幫大家解惑
仲葳好
各位觀眾大家好
台股在創新高
然後也都快要
突破5萬點了
到底我的持股是
怎麼回事
為什麼它沒動
是套牢了
轉弱了
還是我看不懂行情
它還有發動的可能
OK 好
那我們先把這個問題
稍微分切割開了
那我們第一個先看這個
指數的部分
好 那我們說
其實我們在技術分析
有很精確的詞
就是創高跟突破
對創高跟突破
是有點距離的
對就是說
創高只是它過高了
可是突破是它真的
穩定了
它已經要往上走了
對那我們這個
加權指數它其實在
10月5號之前
它沒有有效的突破
它只是創高
對所以到10月5號
之後才正式的突破
對那所以說
我們當然我們櫃買指數
在10月2號
那邊就已經開始突破了
所以說
我們上個禮拜的時候
你會感覺到
中小型股開始
慢慢比較活潑了
對但是權值股休息
對所以會有這個
輪動的現象
所以說
那就要看你當時
買的股票是哪一種了
對如果說
這個時候主流輪動
是在中小型股
那你就買中小型股
那當然就跟著動了
我就會跟著喜氣洋洋
可是如果說這個時候
漲的是加權指數
那都是漲權值股
那你的股票就不會動
就是叫做市場窄化
就比如說有100檔股票
假設只有10檔股票在漲
就只有十分之一
所以我們叫做窄化
就是那個市場寬度
比較小
好那如果說
有三成甚至到四成
股票都在漲
就是寬度比較夠
那你會發現我們在
上個禮拜的時候啊
我們這個
上漲的各這個
不管是短期或中期的
多方股票
其實都大概兩成多
三成多
所以還是蠻窄的
是對可是到這個禮拜
就感覺不一樣了喔
這個短線的
已經到四成了
那中長期的
已經到三成了
就是很明顯的
漲上來
所以必須這兩個
指數的表現跟
這個結構
都改善了
那這樣子我們
的這個散戶會比較有感
就是說這個行情
真的上來了
沒錯沒錯
那我們來看一下
圖的部分
那我們看到這個
大漲的這一天
漲了1000多點
好所以這個才
這個時候什麼
才叫做有效的
這根才叫做有效突破
就是10月5號那天
對那可是上個禮拜
這個地方叫什麼
這個只是叫做創高
所以你會感覺到說
曇花一現
漲完就熄火了
所以說這一根
你才會覺得
比較有感
好那如果是中小型股呢
你會發現為什麼
上禮拜就開始有感覺
因為你看
連續漲了三四天了
對
從上禮拜大概三四五
這樣就連著漲過來
所以說它會表現得
比較穩健
中小型股先漲
不過目前為止的話
都是屬於健康輪漲的
過程
我覺得是OK
好再來就是
我們剛剛提到
這個所謂的這個
均線多空比的概念
就是短線多方個股
你看上個禮拜
多方排列股票才28點多
那這個中長期的才20%
所以說很少
才才兩成三成
可是這禮拜不一樣喔
你看短線多方
已經到40了
對那中長期的
已經到三成
所以說這個結構上
就相對的很強
所以感覺我們現在
整個市場趨勢
應該確實像是
指數會持續創高
往這個方向走上去
所以多頭的股票
也開始慢慢變多了
所以我也不用太著急
說不定我那個綠油油的
馬上就有機會翻紅了
所以接下來我們可以
抱持比較樂觀的心情
真的有可能會遍地開花
雨露均霑嗎
以目前情況看是這樣子
對我們等一下會講到
多頭看支撐這件事
我再跟大家聊
OK
好所以相信很多人
現在最在意
或最煩惱的
一定就是說
大盤漲了
可是我的股票沒漲
像我剛剛提到嘛
我的還綠油油
那我這時候
就要開始想了
我的到底是
短期的被套牢呢
還是還沒輪到我而已
我要續抱
等待它蓄勢待發
旭日東升的那一刻
那我們在檢視一檔股票
其實要看很多指標啦
不管技術面籌碼面
大概會有十多個
那我們這邊講最簡單
常用的
就是說
第一個就是我們說
會先看籌碼面
那籌碼面基本上
我的習慣會看
四個主要指標
就是看三大法人
然後再看融資融券
再看主力指標
跟買賣家數
看這四個
這樣就可以了
簡單的
好那如果說
籌碼還集中
好再來就是你
指數在盤整
可是你的20日線還上揚
只要具備籌碼集中
20日線還在上揚
那這檔股票你
就不用太擔心
整理完之後基本上
會往多方前進
好可是如果反過來
你的股票是籌碼分散
而且20日線已經下彎了
那你要小心說
這個可能隨時會
跌破盤整區間
對所以要看這種情況
甚至已經做頭的
就要更危險
好那我們來看一下
這兩個很標準的個案
剛好剛好顛倒
好一樣的
像聯茂
它之前是不是還在盤整
對可是盤整過程中
20日線
就是這條粉紅色的
對
是不是還在上揚
是
對那這個時候你
就不用太緊張
那加上它籌碼
雖然法人有賣一些些
但是賣不多
所以這種我們都
還可以接受
那所以它後來還有機會
往上走
好可是反過來像這一檔
好你看盤整過程中
哇這條粉紅色的20日線
很明顯的是下彎了
已經下彎了
對那隨時你要小心
這個可能會跌破
而且它籌碼非常弱
所以說就是兩個
很典型的不同的
一個多一個空
可是很多人
聽到這裡可能開始
又會想說
既然弱的要處理掉
那我當然希望
那把這個已經轉弱的
賣掉
然後呢
去往新的
比較強的標的去前進
可是有沒有可能說
現在因為股票輪動的
這麼快
我才剛剛準備好
要買的
結果一追
它就開始跌了
或者是我才剛把
我覺得要轉弱的賣掉了
可是誰知道
我一賣掉它就漲起來了
這是散戶常遇到的狀況
有沒有可能就兩頭空
就是我們常講說
書上都教我們要
汰弱留強對不對
結果我把弱的賣掉
弱的就漲上去
我把強的賣掉
把強的追上去
結果它就掛了
對不對
我們說汰弱留強這件事
本質上是沒有錯啦
只是說你應該有一些
更嚴謹的條件
那我們先講第一件事
就是說
這個強勢股
那跟漲多股
其實它通常是
同一件事情
對因為強勢股
一定是漲多了嘛
對不對好
但是問題是
漲多的強勢股
它有幾個現象
出現的時候
你要稍微留意一下
第一個就是
有沒有出現正乖離過大
對就是短線急漲過熱
好二個是什麼呢
上漲過程中有沒有
出現價量背離
對那如果
沒有價量背離
那就OK
就是屬於價漲量增
很穩健的狀態
也不用擔心
好再來第三個就是
我們剛剛講的
上漲過程中籌碼也都是
很健康
法人還是繼續買
好只要具備這三件事情
那強勢股還有機會
持續維持多方續漲的結構
對 所以也不用因為
擔心它已經漲了
好長一段
就不敢再繼續追
其實它還是有空間的
還是有空間的對
好那再來
就是你剛剛提到
說說
有沒有怎麼避免說我們
把這個
剛好顛倒
我們汰弱留強
對變成汰強留弱了
對好那這時候就要回到
我們這個在上課
或者我們在
上課訂閱分享會
常講的一些
技術分析的濾網
好像我在個人在做這個
過濾的時候
我大概會有十幾個
技術分析工具
對那其實
這樣子整個跑一輪下來
你就可以幫股票打分數
對那通常股票如果能夠
具備八分以上
那基本上是安全的
對那如果你要去做
加碼的動作
至少要8.5分
甚至九分
這種股票才能夠買
對
所以說不能不是說
你看到一檔股票
或聽到一個消息
或者是看到一個新聞
或者是出一個財報
你就衝進去了
這樣是很危險的
簡單講一下
就是有幾個
主要的工具
第一個就是
我們講說第一個
就是趨勢嘛
就是第一個
你要多頭趨勢
第二個是你不要漲太多
位階不要太高
我們說漲高
漲多就是最大的風險嘛
對不對
好那再來是型態
我們希望是最好是
底部型態剛剛漲
再不然就是剛剛我們講
那檔
盤整完有旗形
又要續漲
好再來就是它不要有
太大的壓力
上漲過程中
前波壓力不要太多
好再來就是
我們剛剛說的
籌碼面
好那最後一個很重要的
就是我們要
目標價
我們希望能夠透過
技術面去估算出
有效的目標價
其實還有有四五種方法
可以估得出來
對
好那再來就是最後一個
有突破訊號
好那如果說這些每一個
條件它都
拿到分數
不用滿分
就是拿到一分或0.5分
那這檔股票基本上
就會符合八分以上
哇沒錯沒錯
所以這張很重要
大家一定要記起來
對很好用的工具
對如果你對
如果你對技術分析
熟悉的話
你習慣性的
把這張巡檢表跑一遍
可以避免掉很多地雷
有一些人呢
可能欸
已經套牢了
或者是有些人
他的股票有獲利
那甚至有一些人
可能還在觀望中
那現在這三種人
應該要在
這樣子的情況之下
怎麼樣來操作呢
好
那我們現在
先從第一種開始
就是說你買進去
它就不動了
對先擺著好
那這時候我覺得
大家不要急著說
你就要趕快
去攤平加碼幹嘛
不要
你要先確定
一樣回到
我剛剛那個選股的條件
好如果它
還在健康的狀態
那這時候你可以續抱
那等到它重新轉強
你才去做加碼
對不要急著加碼
好那第二種是說
很幸運的你買了
假設100塊買進
它已經漲到120塊了
你也不用說急著賣掉
你可以透過技術面
去估算
它的漲幅滿足空間
或者是說
去設定
所謂的移動式停利
比如說你可以
看五日線啊
看KD指標啊
等等的
那這些訊號出現
你再去做調節就好了
你也不用說漲多了
就急著想要賣掉
好那如果空手的人
投資人不要說
那之前一直有恐高症
有沒有
就是就是指數一直漲
三萬四萬五萬
你說都不敢追
好很簡單
這時候你
採取所謂的漸進式加碼
你不要說
因為今天
我們衝一千多點上去
你就all in了
對你你可以
假設你有100萬
你可以先分成
把它拆三批
30萬
我們先佈局一點基本的
比如說ETF型的
市值的啦
或者是一些權值股
比較安全安全的
你先建立一點基本部位
那到時候你
要再做第二階段
你會比較踏實一點
所以我們有
這三種不同的投資人
給予大家一些參考
好那我們再講哦
三種人它其實有
三種不同的
一個操作手法
但是有一個共通點啦
不要因為情緒太滿
就是看到哇大漲大跌
然後就跟著
有一點衝動的去佈局
這樣子是大忌啦
所以不管你看到
你自己是屬於
現在套牢中的啊
或者是空手中的啊
或者是
有一些些小獲利的
還是要穩住自己的情緒
然後留有
自己操作的SOP
是最安全的
好最後我們想
幫大家再加問一題
其實現在指數
已經近5萬了
感覺隨時都有
突破的可能性
老師到底
要建議怎麼操作
對啊 怎麼操作
OK好那我們說
第一個就是說
一樣的概念就是說
我們現在還是回到說
你原本是中低持股的人
好那你不要說
因為指數創新高了
那你就急著要哇
好像趕快怕這個高鐵
沒有趕上車有沒有
趕快要撞撞撞撞車門
要衝進去不用
你還是可以確定說
你的個股
是不是真的有效突破
之後
你再去做加碼的動作
這是第一個
那第二個事情說
我還是希望
大家能夠分批啦
採取分批
不要說你一次
就急著all in
那要預留說
比如說可能短線漲上去
三五天後
馬上過熱有拉回
那這時候我們
還有有加碼的機會
對至少你手上
還有一點資金
對還有資金對
好那再來就是說
我們在多頭高檔的時候
第一個就是說
不要去猜高點
我們常講說多頭看支撐
不看壓力
空頭看壓力不看支撐
所以說只要現在往上
在進行過程當中
那支撐沒有跌破
它就是多頭
雖然說我們現在
其實在上漲過程中
坦白講有價量背離
稍微但是不嚴重
對所以說它還是在多頭
那我們現在
如果以我們剛剛講的
這個目前指數的
長紅K棒二分之一
去看的話
大概最短最短的支撐
是在49250
最最最短這個地方
即使回測到這個地方
都還在可接受範圍
都還算很強喔
那甚至說
稍微再回到一點點
五日線
我覺得
都還在可以接受範圍
所以不是說看20日線
那已經是最低底線了
那個有點慢了
對如果你是對
那會有點太弱了一點
不要不要回到那麼多
回到那麼多
會比較有點辛苦
好那再來就是說
我們在這個多頭
我們說多頭做多
空頭做空嘛
盤整不要做
所以說
我們要做順勢操作
所以多頭的時候
我們在做多的過程當中
你可以少量經營
你甚至保守的
你可以觀望
你就看戲
但是你心情要平靜
好那你也可以
持股中高水位
也沒關係
因為你之前買的嘛
那去做加碼
但是有一件事情
千萬不要做
就是放空
對你不要說
因為它漲了五萬多點
漲到五萬點了
看不順眼
然後就去空它
我就不信它可以破五萬
我要加空
不要不要不要做這種事
太恐怖對
因為我們常講說
順勢操作
所以說多頭做多
空頭做空
盤整不要做
那現在是這樣子
指數是多頭
雖然我們台股是真的是
全世界大概最強的
那還是要面對
這個真的發生的事情
是這個很很恭喜大家啦
那你還是要
做多為主這樣子
對恭喜大家
一起見證了台股的
對對見證這個
這個不可思議啦
沒錯真的是不可思議
好了那今天我們
來幫大家畫四個重點哦
第一就是指數創高
其實不代表雨露均霑
每個個股都會漲
你還是要先看
這個多頭股票的比例
是不是有增加
第二呢
就是套牢股啊
你要從20日線
還有籌碼的集中度來看
它的這個結構
再來第三呢
就是建立
股票的評分標準嘛
最後呢就是
套牢啊 獲利 空手
不管你現在
處於哪一個階段
分批操作都是最重要的
如果今天老師
跟我們講解了
蠻多好用的工具
跟實用的方法
可是如果
我們的觀眾朋友
想要學得更完整的話
聽說老師第四季
還有一個
更深入更進階的課程嗎
那我們這樣
在做這個影片
YouTube影片是很短
十幾分鐘而已
所以其實多數
只能聊一些觀念
跟一點點的技術分析
那如果大家
想要更精進的話
就可以來參考
我們的這個這個
技術分析課程
那我們在第四季
有三堂課
那在10月份講的是
這個主力這個離場策略
就是你可以跟著主力
一起跑掉
對你怎麼判斷說
主力在高檔跑掉了
我們跟他一起跑
好那第二個是
停利跟停損的策略
大家很多人
都只會買股票
但是不知道怎麼賣股票
對所以這兩課很重要
好 那第三堂課就在講
我個人很多選股的秘方
小小撇步
大補帖
對 在這一堂課
會再跟各位做
當然我們這個
只是簡易的這個說明
那我們等一下
會把完整的
課程架構跟大綱
放在我們的影片下面
大家可以參考
沒問題所以
如果想要更了解
老師的投資方法
可以點擊下方的連結
了解一下Q4
我們K線捕手 楊忠憲老師
致勝班的課程資訊
那我們今天非常感謝
楊忠憲老師的分享
謝謝老師
謝謝
好那我是仲葳
我們Smart投資教室
下課囉
下次再見 大家拜拜